you guys totally freaked out
hi there it's associate editor Matta
Spinelli standing in for reviewer
Randolph Ramsay to tell you about
Minecraft story mode oh man that was
close there are plenty of stories out
there that use Minecraft world and look
but minecraft story mode is something
different it comes from developer
telltale games the same company that
recently delivered adult focused
adventure games like the wolf among us
or The Walking Dead but you won't find
any murder or sex here this game is
aimed to be family friendly
entertainment think Goonies instead of
Game of Thrones the more recent telltale
games have hit the ground running
narrative Lee but this first episode of
minecraft story mode gets off to a slow
start the stakes the characters
motivations and all the pieces for the
entire series is overarching story only
fall into place right at the end of this
episode runtime it feels like an
extended prologue rather than the first
act of a grand adventure that's not to
say that there's no emotional investment
to be found here there's some gentle
humor some dashes of excitement and a
reverence for the world in mythos of
Minecraft it helps that the main
character here Jesse serves as a proxy
for a typical minecraft fan jesse who
you can choose to be either male or
female is enthusiastic about the world
she's in geeking out about going to
Endor Khan and Dena anyone have courage
enough to brave the hostile environment
of the nether Jesse in other words is
every ten-year-old who watches Minecraft
videos on YouTube the narrative is pure
minecraft reverence Jesse and her
friends get embroiled in a mystery
involving the famous order of the stone
a group that defeated the powerful ender
dragon but has since split up mysterious
circumstances the main threat that needs
to be dealt with is another feared and
powerful creature in the Minecraft
mythos and everything else is a direct
lift from the original game story mode
looks sounds and feels like well
minecraft the gameplay however is
typical telltale a mix of narrative
choices some light puzzles and QuickTime
events there are no major twists or
turns in this first episode of Minecraft
story mode
it's an admirable journey for Jesse and
Friends and if you're a parent waiting
to play this with the child
there's nothing here in terms of
questionable content your biggest
choices tend to revolve around which of
your friends to support or which
character to help and give
situations everything so far seems
black-and-white the good guys are good
the bad guys are bad although some
much-needed gray is injected right near
the end but while the narrative meanders
there are several engaging sequences
that require quick reflexes including
being pursued by that a fer mentioned
minecraft Big Bad and a ride on a
minecart through the nether there are
some nice touches to the tie in a
mechanical building component of
Minecraft proper story mode no you won't
actually have to build anything as you
do in Minecraft all building is handled
via QTE but little tasks like creating a
shelter when the characters find
themselves outside at night and having
to create items using a crafting table
are nice touches that lend the game even
more minecraft flavor and it's that
flavor that helps propel the first
episode of minecraft story mode along
even when the story itself only begins
to hint at the scope of the adventure
head it's a pleasant start packed with
individual events but featuring little
in the way of narrative propulsion but
when you reach the end of this episode
you'll want more perhaps like most
outstanding minecraft creations
minecraft story mode just needs a little
more time to build its dharmic it's over
we aren't talking about it anymore we
could have maybe done like a multi level
thing but that's - Liam I mean it's it's
cool let's keep it together guys
you